public sénat et le centre national du
livre présente livres et vous
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le livret vous
je suis ravi de vous retrouver cette
semaine autour d'une question
l'individualisme et qui les nuits de la
démocratie pour répondre à cette
question aujourd'hui j'ai le grand
plaisir d'accueillir deux invités
raphaël glucksmann bonjour à vous
bonjour bienvenue dans le livre et vous
je suis ravi de toi vous fait paraître
aux éditions à l'arrêt un ouvrage qui
s'appelle les enfants du vide de
l'impasse individualiste réveil citoyen
un ouvrage qui s'est hissé en tête des
ventes juste après sa sortie et vous
venez de créer un
un mouvement qui s'appelle place
publique dans le premier meeting a eu
lieu il ya quelques temps j'ai rencontré
déjà beaucoup de gens vous me direz tout
à l'heure de quoi il s'agit à vos côtés
se trouve l'historien et philosophe
marcel gauchet bonjour à vous bonjour
bienvenue d'un livret vous on vous doit
de nombreux ouvrages parmi lesquels si
je devais n'en citer que deux qui ont
marqué l'imaginaire des lecteurs
français
je citerai le désenchantement du monde
et le malheur français dans lesquelles
vous teniez déjà l'individualisme
peut-être comme causes du malaise
démocratique et pourtant c'est d'un
individu et quel individu est dingue
dont vous raconter l'histoire dans votre
dernier livre il s'agit de robespierre
l'homme qui nous divise le plus aux
éditions gallimard avant de vous
présenter plus précisément car vos
parcours respectifs permettre sans doute
de répondre à la question je voudrais
vous la poser directement afin
d'entendre votre réponse
pensez vous que l'individualisme soit
l'ennemi ou mises à l'exercice même de
la démocratie
rafik semaine si l'individualisme est
tout puissant
si le citoyen s'efface devant l'individu
si l'homo economicus derrière l'individu
qui se prend lui même comme horizon de
toute son existence de toute chose et et
triomphe contre eux et bien la figure du
citoyen alors oui on a un problème et la
démocratie libérale 16 de marcher sur
ses deux pieds et la démocratie y entre
en crise et je pense que c'est largement
le cas aujourd'hui
marcel gauchet tous pareils justement
d'exprimer diagnostic que jeunes
auxquels je ne peux souscrire
il ya un paradoxe de l'individualisme la
démocratie le fondement de la démocratie
c'est un individu ali la finalité de la
démocratie c'est un individualiste c'est
à dire le bien être des personnes prises
individuellement
et en même temps une certaine version de
cet individualisme peut corrompre la
démocratie jusqu'à la rendre impuissante
et réinstaller ce qui est son contraire
absolu le règne du plus fort la loi de
des forces mutuelle de chaque individu
au détriment de la capacité de pouvoir
collectif veut d'aller vers une cité
juste et pourtant vous l'avez dit le
fondement de la démocratie c'est
l'individu talent puisque
l'individualisme le but aussi parce que
personne ne voudrait d'un état ou d'un
régime politique où l'individu serait
absolument dissous dans la masse est une
jeune art absolu c'est le cauchemar
absolu mais la démocratie libérale il
dans ces deux mots il ya démocratie et
libérale libéral c'est ce qui part de
l'individu et qui se termine vers
l'individu c'est ce qui sent que tu as
he is l'espace privé l'autonomie de
l'individu
le fait que vous puissiez vous menez
votre vie comme vous l'entendez créer
votre entreprise couché avec qui vous
voulez et vivre votre existence d'être
libre mais il ya un autre pôle dans la
démocratie libérale c'est le pôle
démocratique où là c'est plus tellement
l'individu qui est l'horizon de toute
chose c'est l'existence du peuple en
tant que peuple en tant que communauté
politique qui prend en main son propre
destin et donc qui entend exercer sa
souveraineté et sa souveraineté peut
aussi s'exercer contre l'individu et
donc c'est ce système de la démocratie
libérale et bien c'est une contradiction
dynamique une sorte de dialectique entre
ce pôle individualiste et ce pôle
collectiviste si on tombe vous avez
vraiment si on tombe dans le
collectivisme absolue eh bien on se
retrouve au cambodge en une 75 et
franchement personne n'a envie d'y vivre
et heureusement parce c'est la fin de
ces utopies ultra collectiviste mais si
on tombe complètement dans le pôle
libéral de la démocratie libérale c'est
à dire s'ils rompent la sq l'individu au
dessus de tout autre chose
eh bien on risque de tomber dans
l'atomisation dans l'anomie dans la
jungle dans le l'absence de règles et
l'absence de sens commun à notre
existence collective et on risque
aujourd'hui ce d'évitement là mais en at
il jamais été autrement marcel gaucher
vous faisait le même diagnostic au début
années 80 mais parce que nous sommes
dans une configuration historique où ce
problème se pose à nouveau
il avait été il a été éclipsé au cours
du 20e siècle
on peut dire de 1914 aux années 1970 par
une autre comparu une configuration
historique où la priorité a été ou est
au mouvement de masse aux évalue
complètement évanouie aujourd'hui ou à
un cadre beaucoup plus satisfaisant qui
était incarnée par les états sociaux qui
réalise aime tant bien que mal ce
compromis contre la redistribution
collective au service des individus
et puis nous sommes entrés dans un
nouveau courir une histoire où nous
sommes dans un nouveau cycle de crise de
la démocratie quand sous le signe de l'
individualisme depuis les années 1970
après on peut détailler de façon
complexe le beaucoup plus raffinée la
chronologie de ces événements mais je
pense que c'est très important à faire
d'ailleurs
mais le il ya eu une inflexion du cours
de nos sociétés à partir des années 1970
par rapport à ce qu'était la période
antérieure qui de 1945 à 1975 prenons
des dap ronde a été placée sur le signe
de la réponse des démocraties au
totalitarisme c'est à dire précisément
au despotisme des masses en théorie et
parce qu'en fait de masse bénéficier par
beaucoup du système tice exerçaient en
leur nom
nous avons tenté il ya eu un moment
déquilibre ne sait ce qu'il faut
chercher dans la démocratie
c'est un équilibre entre la puissance
collective et les libertés individuelles
la chose du monde la plus difficile à
faire en réalité et src appelé pendant
longtemps la social démocratie et sur sa
clause sociale démocratique et dit bien
les choses et que lui aujourd'hui et
jeté à la poubelle avec des grands
sourires par tout le monde mais qui en
réalité a permis l'existence d'une
période comme ça où le collectif et
l'individuel pouvait fonctionner
ensemble parce qu'il y avait une forme
d'équilibré et c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que c'est je pense
qu'on peut avoir des approches
dogmatiques sur l'individualisme
il ya des moments dans l'histoire ou
être libéral et placer l'un des droits
individuels au dessus de tout eh bien ça
relève d'une forme d'héroïsme de la
pensée être libéral à moscou en 1970
c'est héroïque
être libéral à san francisco en 2018 ça
relève pas de la même disposition
d'esprit et c'est quand même largement
moins héroïque puisque ça devient
complètement conformiste c'est épouser
l'air du temps et pousser dans le sens
du vent et donc il ya comme ça dans
parce que la démocratie libérale à un
objet complexe et que en fait il ya une
dynamique
il ya des moments de l'histoire où en
fait épouser trop l'un des pôles de
cette démocratie libérale c'est en fait
contribué à la crise alors face au même
constat d'une fatigue ou d'une fragilité
de la démocratie aujourd'hui vous avez
l'un et l'autre proposé chacun un
travail différent mais depuis bien
longtemps
le dernier en date ce sont les deux
livres que j'ai cité en début d'émission
rappelé mme x man les enfants du vide et
marcel gauchet robespierre l'homme qui
nous divise le plus dans les enfants
d'une ville rappelle glucksmann et vous
disiez la démocratie c'est une histoire
d' équilibre entre l'individu et le
collectif et le peuple vous parti d'une
image l'image d'un tableau de caravage
ou l'envoi sans mathieu qui tient en
équilibre sur un tabouret et tous le
libre
vous vous demandez ce qu'il faudrait
pour que cette tabouret bosque lui d'un
côté ou plutôt du l'autre c'est à dire
c'est à dire combien cette question de
l'équilibré pour vous central dans la
réflexion politique et combien en fait
toute une affaire de nuances bien loin
des engagements et des discours
dithyrambique dogmatique on entend
aujourd'hui non
on peut parfois devoir être radical
parce que si le tabou raids pour voir ce
que ces combats de la manne et qualité
circulation et c'est ce que j'essaye
d'opposer c'est qu'on peut avoir une
pensée radicale mais il faut éviter la
tentation dogmatique la tentation
dogmatique en gros c'est de dire ce que
je vous propose comme idée est bien est
valable partout et toujours
mais ça c'est du dogmatisme la pensée
radicale
ça peut tout à fait être une réponse à
une situation radical et ce tableau de
caravage moi qui me m'obsède qui guident
dans l'écriture du livre mais qui
m'obsède depuis longtemps il m'obsède
parce qu'en fait c'est apparemment le
tableau le plus lisse de carlos est
presque tous les tableaux de car elles
ont été refusées par l'église parce que
c'était un punk
de son époque et qu' il n' y ait une
madone qui était en fait une prostituée
il montrait les pieds sales des pèlerins
devant le christ à chaque fois il y
avait quelque chose de totalement
blasphématoire dans sa peinture et là
vous avez saint mathieu qui écrit
l'évangile sous la dictée d'un ange et
c'est absolument parfait c'est lisse et
harmonieux c'est presque ennuyeux pour
un tableau de caravage et pourtant ce
tableau là moi il me il me fascinait
parce que il y avait une forme de
malaise dans ce tableau et j'arrivais
pas ça pourquoi alors au début je me
sentais que le problème était moi je
l'étais trop punk pour aimer un tableau
aussi lisse et en réalité je me suis
rendu compte au bout d'un moment à force
de le contempler ce que j'allais à
l'église tous les matins quand je
travaillais à rome est pas approprié
mais pour regarder ce tableau et je me
suis rendu compte qu'en fait saint
mathieu qui écrit l'évangile est
agenouillé sur un tabouret qui menace de
vous tomber dessus et que donc dans sa
chute il va entraîner l'ensemble lange
le kosmos tou tou l'ordre du monde
chrétien et c'est ça qui produit le
trouble est en fait ce tabouret pour moi
qui fais la démocratie et donc toute
pensée politique doit revenir à cette
simple question dans quel sens penche le
tabouret et si on veut produire une
pratique politique alors dans quel sens
on doit pousser pour que le tabouret ne
tombe pas et si on se trompe sur le sens
du tabouret de la chute du tabouret et
bien on contribue à plonger nos
démocraties dans la crise et il me
semble largement les élites occidentales
aujourd'hui et bien pousse dans le sens
de la chute du tabouret c'est à dire que
dans une époque déjà survalorise
l'individu on va avoir des discours
ultra individualiste qui vont triompher
votre livre se présente comme une forme
de deux tragédies en deux actes en tout
cas il ya deux actes est ce une tragédie
ou pas je ne sais pas parce que vous en
appelez justement un retour à la
tragédie
nous avons perdu ce sens tragique que
désormais nous préférons rire des tweets
de trump en gros que de prendre
conscience de la tragédie qui nous qui
nous arrive est donc danser dans ces
deux actes en fait vous vous adressez
certes au lecteur mais dès le début du
livre vous semblez nous mettre lecteurs
vous dites nous autres nous
intellectuels humaniste militant
humaniste partisans la société ouverte
défenseurs des droits humains et autres
citoyens cosmopolite
qui sommes incapables d'endiguer là
vague nationalistes et autoritaires qui
s'abat sur nos sociétés
mais si vous adresser à des gens qui
sont qui font partie qui sont de votre
côté vous n'allez pas convaincre les
autres non mais moi je m'adresse aux
gens vous dites nous et vous définissez
bien sûr et je définis ces gens là et
ces gens là je le redis il va falloir
qu'on fasse quelque chose d'extrêmement
douloureux qui est de s'exercer à mourir
à nous mêmes c'est à dire que vous
prenez la figure de socrate pour une
heure actuelle parce que c'est très
exigeant
ce qui est extrêmement choquant et
pourquoi le discours de ces gens là se
noue dans lequel je m'inclus est de
moins en moins audible c'est parce que
en fait alors même que le monde nous
donne tort
eh bien nous continuons à ressembler à
ses curés qui voit dans la désertion des
fidèles la preuve qu'ils ont raison de
pester contre la terre entière et donc
ce que j'explique c'est que si on veut
retrouver un discours de gauche audible
il va falloir apprendre à mourir à soi
et au lieu de penser que c'est le real
qui a tort est bien temps en temps faire
un examen de conscience et se dire qu'on
a pu se tromper de chemin et donc moi je
viens du logiciel philosophique de
pensée de deux rapports au monde c'est
un logiciel fondée sur l'idée des droits
de l'homme et je ne renie absolument
rien des droits de l'homme mais ce que
j'essaye de comprendre c'est comment
en fait en se limitant à ce logiciel là
aux droits des individus aux droits de
la personne au droit des minorités aux
droits des communautés on rate un la
politique on a délégitimé la politique
on l'a réduite à quelque chose qui en
fait la rend impuissante et 2 on a
complètement oublié la question sociale
et donc il va falloir qu'on révise notre
notre propre logiciel de penser oui très
bien mais quand lorsque vous dites nous
c'est ça une certaine partie de la
population qui ne s'en doute pas
majoritaire c'est ça qui est étonnant
vous écrive un livre vous adresser à des
gens qui pensent déjà comme vous mais
non enfin oui mais pour leur proposer
quelque chose qui va plaire aussi à des
gens qui ne pensent pas à priori puisque
comme nous puisque le problème c'est que
j'essaye de leur dire arrêtez de penser
que vous avez raison pour pouvoir
justement engager un dialogue avec ce
que vous êtes hanche
vous pouvez regarder tes dans ce livre
ce qui est ce que j'ai essayé de faire
c'est de faire un livre qui propose une
pensée
progressiste de gauche pour discuter des
termes sans dresser de liste d'ennemis à
abattre sans dresser des listes
d'intellectuels réactionnaire à
proscrire sens en fait cherché à se
montrer qu'on existe dans le miroir de
la fatwa lancée contre ceux qui ne
pensent pas comme nous juste en mourir à
soi même mais c'est vrai qu'en ce moment
la bouche
les mauvaises langues vous diront qu
elle est déjà morte mais elle est morte
parce qu'elle refuse de mourir elle même
moi je le pensais il faut mourir une
deuxième fois quand il faut merci un ami
ce qu'il faut c'est que quand on perd
des débats culturels quand on perd des
élections il faut s'arrêter
deux ombres réfléchir retourner sur le
terrain comprendre pourquoi les gens ne
votent plus pour vous et deuxièmement
aller à la bibliothèque grand palais ici
à la maison eric lire des livres essayer
de travailler en fait et ce travail là
il n'est pas fait il n'est pas parce
qu'on est à priori sûr qu'on a raison
quand on est de gauche on pense que de
toute façon si les gens peuvent voter
brousse parce qu'ils sont bêtes genre
est d'accord avec ça marcel gauchet sur
le travail qui manque à la gauche
quelques uns des intellectuels de gauche
puis ceux qui sont qui sont présents qui
s'activent écrivent à s'activer
certainement oui l'actif de problèmes de
l'activité c'est qu'elles soient
pertinentes mais qui écrivent aussi
quand même un chantal mouche qui écrit
pour un populisme de gauche frédéric
lordon enfin ya des intellectuels
beaucoup de bien sur ya d'ailleurs
toutes sortes de choses juste à en tirer
de leurs livres je dois dire que ça me
réjouit profondément on entendre raphaël
glucksmann parler sans soulever de
scandale et se faire précisément ranger
dans la catégorie des intellectuels
réactionnaires qui est là mentionné car
pour avoir tenu des propos d'une disons
consonant avec les siens pas forcément
identique on vous a entendu j'ai eu
droit comme c'est stalinien en bonne et
due forme donc je vois qu'il ya un
progrès qu'il se met dans les esprits je
me réjouis que graf heinz luckman puisse
lui se faire entendre
vous êtes encore plus critique que
raphaël noxon sur les droits de l'homme
par exemple mais j'aimerais qu'on
précise ce qu'on attendait l'arrivée
avec c'est le point crucial c'est très
étrange de s'en prendre aux droits de
l'homme
alors justement il ne s'agit pas de s'en
prendre aux bretons
d'abord premières observations les gens
qui parlent des droits de l'homme ne
savent pas ce que c'est c'est à dire je
constate l'insignifiance de la
production sur la signification de ces
finales qu'est ce que ça dit comme un
article d'évangile d'où il sort comment
sans qu'il n'ait j'ai pris la peine de
travailler assez longuement sur la
généalogie de cette idée est de la
manière dont elle s'est inscrite dans
l'histoire et je constate que ce travail
est très peu fait on ne travaille pas
beaucoup justement à gauche sur ce genre
de thème les droits de l'homme
définissent un critère de légitimité est
en fait un critère de légitimité qui va
très loin puisqu'il se substitue aux
critères de légitimité religieux qui a
dominé toute l'histoire humaine
donc ils sont le fondement de que de ce
que nous pouvons considérer comme juste
dans le monde où nous sommes et ça il
s'agit pas de s'en prendre aux droits de
l'homme d'ailleurs qu'elles font cela
aurait-il il n'y a aucune autre idée
capable de jouer le même rôle que donc
ils sont un fondement légitime de nos
sociétés et c'est leur grand privilège
que d'avoir réussi à installer ce choyé
de sens
ou alors leur centre la question à
partir de là c'est que c'est on dire aux
droits de l'homme et quel usage en
sait-on tout est là il s'agit évidemment
pas de critiquer les droits de l'homme
il s'agit d'examiner l'usal que nous est
à terre est-ce qu'ils passent trop bien
dans cet âge ce qui le fait bien
précisément la dérive individualiste qui
en découlent très aisément la première
application des droits de l'homme et les
politiques c'est la souveraineté du
peuple c'est à dire nous n'y a de
pouvoir légitime que parce que tous les
citoyens sont en mesure de contribuer à
la désignation des gouvernants et de
leurs représentants qu'il peut contester
cette idée n'est pas de sens mais les
droits de l'homme deviennent tout à fait
autre chose il ya une histoire qu'il
faut retracer et ils deviennent tout à
fait autre chose quand ils viennent le
droit des individus contre leur société
par exemple où le droit des individus en
apesanteur relativement aux conséquences
de leur conduite de leurs actes
alors cela roule nerfs la revendiquer un
endroit pour faire valoir sans lundi
son individualité avant le pestacle
victimisation qui peut découler de
chaque donnée en effet cette expression
victimaire mais historiquement la
première grande critique qui a été fait
des droits de l'homme celle du marxisme
qui comporte un noyau de vérité quelles
que soient ensuite les erreurs qui ont
pu renaître
elles portent sur le domaine économique
la première expression des libertés
individuelles
ça va être le droit d'initiative
économique le capitalisme pour faire
vite simple le droit d'être à l'origine
du capital et c'est bien sûr dans une
société sans droits de l'homme sans un
droit d'initiative individuelle pour
utiliser la propriété qu'est celle du
capital il n'y a pas de sens à un
capitalisme quelconque donc les droits
de l'homme ça donne immédiatement une
traduction sous forme d'économies
concurrents à l'usman cette économie
concurrentielle pose immédiatement le
problème démocratique du contrôle de
cette concurrence de sa régulation est
d'ailleurs admise dans nos sociétés mais
jusqu'à quel point
et puis il ya des expressions qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui sociétale de
l'individu en fait ce sont
essentiellement de celle là par exemple
que raphaël glucksmann traite dans son
livre c'est à dire la la capacité
outre toutes les dimensions
psychologiques la culture qui va avec
qui conduit à la totale indifférence à
l'idée de justice sociale dans un monde
de ce triste individu de droit l'idée de
justice sociale perd tout sens c'est ce
que les théoriciens libéraux les plus
conséquents argumenté de façon très
convaincante graphics and mail et les
droits de l'homme peuvent aussi servir
de d'arguments et de référence pour
lutter justement contre les dérives du
capitalisme c'est à dire que bien sûr et
aussi au nom des droits de l'homme con
con qu'on va pouvoir lutter contre
l'oppression sociale quand elle viol ou
la possibilité pour les individus d'être
libre en les condamnant l esclavage ou à
un ou à la misère trop grande pour
pouvoir survivre et donc les droits de
l'homme en fait c'est un référent mais
ça ne peut pas être le seul référent ça
peut pas être le seul horizon deniers et
et est par ailleurs il
il ya quand même quelque chose qu'il
faut noter c'est que l'on parle tous
tout le temps des droits de l'homme
or c'est quand même une déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen et les
révolutionnaires français quand ils
rédigent les droits de l'homme la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen c'est des gens qui maîtrisent
parfaitement la langue française
beaucoup mieux que nous beaucoup mieux
que les plaignants des droits de l'homme
et de la femme
oui mais j'ai tout ici l'homme avec un
grand h mais clients inclut évidemment
là il fallait débat n'est pas clos mais
on fait comme s'il s'agissait d'une
répétition il ne pense pas du tout faire
une répétition quand il est la
déclaration des droits l'homme et du
citoyen il pense faire une addition et
ce qui est intéressant c'est que nous on
zappe complètement la deuxième partie et
du citoyen alors même que les droits de
l'homme et les droits du site rien
peuvent s'opposer c'est à dire que les
droits du citoyen peuvent être un devoir
pour l'homme pour l'individu et c'est ça
qu'on n'arrive plus à faire en fait
aujourd'hui c'est à comprendre que et
bien en tant que citoyen je peut
m'obliger en tant qu'individu folle et
de voir si c'est ça le droit de raphaël
glucksmann membres de la communauté
politique c'est de la nation française
est bien ce droit-là peut aller à
l'encontre des libertés individuelles de
raphaël glucksmann en tant qu'individu
qui est expert suivre toute sa vie ses
propres désirs
et ça c'est une dichotomie une forme de
schizophrénie enfin une dichotomie qui
est exigé de nous par la république la
chose commune et qui est extrêmement
complexe à vivre en fait c'est une
ascèse et ce conflit-là cette tension là
donc on voit à quel point les droits de
l'homme crystallis attention entre
individualisme et peuples et communautés
on la trouve dès le début en fait dès la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et des
la révolution française et peut-être
mais est elle même incarné dans ce
personnage auquel vous avez consacré un
livre marcel gauchet robespierre dont
vous dites c'est un homme entouré d'un
impénétrable un impénétrable secret et
sur lui on a déposé tous nos fantasmes à
la fois le pire et le meilleur on a
surtout retenu le pire parce qu'on en
fait l'instigateur de la terreur
mais est-ce que c'est par provocation
c'est dans une perspective historique ou
parce que vous pensez que ça figure
aujourd'hui où serait utile que vous
avez décidé d'y consacrer un ouvrage
bien sûr c'est pas pour le plaisir de
faire un livre de connards de
robespierre
mais je n'interdisais à personne ne
s'était pas d'objectif personnel je
pense que c'est l'occasion de il est le
personnage qui permet de revoir le sens
de l'expérience révolutionnaire dans ce
qu'elle a de significatif pour nous
aujourd'hui
au delà des clichés qui se sont
sédimentées pendant deux siècles autour
de cet événement monstre l'un des plus
grands événements de la modernité
occidentale et robespierre est le
personnage qui incarne très exactement
cette dialectique que mentionné à
l'instant raphaël glucksmann dans un
premier temps il est l'homme des droits
de l'homme dans un sens où ils les
oppose à un régime d'oppression
d'autorité de la royauté d'ancien régime
il est l'homme qui défend le plus
radicalement les libertés individuelles
contre un système qui les étouffe et il
va au bout de l'idée d'une manière qui
le distingue parmi le personnel
révolutionnaire il se trouve que les
circonstances que je vais pas commencer
à relater parce qu'elles sont
embrouillées compliqué et il faut les
démonter finement pour les comprendre
qui va se retrouver en position de
pouvoir au nom de ses droits de l'homme
dont il a été le chantre et là on
pourrait dire très simplement il oublie
les droits de l'individu au profit des
droits du citoyen car le citoyen peut
devenir l'oppresseur de l'individu c'est
au nom de la communauté politique et ses
droits il limité il ya un droit de vie
et de mort sur chacun sait ce que
l'utilisation de la guillotine dans la
révolution française fixée dans les
imaginaires il y a une capacité de
passer outre
même les garanties judiciaires qui font
que on est arrêté et questionné condamné
pouvoir se défendre ce qui est
quand même le malheur de la justice
révolutionnaire donc ils incarnent eux
très bien la contradiction autour de
laquelle nous tournons c'est que ce
caractère double des droits de l'homme
qui est au fond le caractère
l'opposition entre liberté égalité au
fond c'est cette opposition là qui
tranche de manière très schématique en
france la gauche sait pas qui est qui je
pense que c'est à lui la distinction
entre la gauche et la pincée beaucoup
plus complet je dirais avec les bronzés
3 il faut il faut justement passer d'une
pensée simple univoque à une pensée
qu'on avait ce faire nous et conduit pas
toujours parce que lui même temps dans
un manichéisme est assez fort en
s'identifiant au peuple qu'il tient pour
vertueux les ai tous les ennemis
seraient du côté du mal c'est le
problème aussi de sa personne mais bien
oui parce que précisément à un moment
donné ils oublient et les circonstances
permettent d' assez facilement de le
comprendre
cette dimension gueule qui exige
d'articuler des choses qui doivent se
retrouver le bien n'est pas toujours du
côté du peuple on est seize sans
sacrifier les putschistes semaine mais
mais ce qu'est ce qui est fascinant dans
la philo de robespierre sais que c'est
pas de l'opposition entre liberté et
égalité à mon avis c'est l'opposition
entre deux conceptions de la liberté
c'est l'opposition entre une liberté
moderne qui est celle de l'individu du
droit de retrait de la possibilité
d'avoir sa propre existence comme on
l'entend de l'amener comme on l'entend
et la liberté antilles qui est celle
d'abord du citoyen qu'est la liberté de
participer au gouvernement et d'incarner
une forme de vertu mais pas forcément au
sens de la morale mais de vertu au sens
de machiavel de deux vertus civiques et
chez robespierre c'est qu'en fait
effectivement le tabouret la bascule
complètement
du côté de la vertu civique c'est à dire
que en gros on nie l'individu et 6 mois
pièces qui m'a fasciné depuis
l'adolescence qui est la mort de danton
de büchner ou en gros un révolutionnaire
qui est poursuivi par les troupes
réactionnaire de la police réactionnaire
des princes allemands écrit sur la
terreur et sur la révolution qui dévore
ses propres enfants alors que lui-même
est révolutionnaire et il est crise
cette pièce sur la confrontation
justement entre la liberté antique qui
est celle de robespierre et la liberté
libidineuse moderne qui est celle de
danton et je sais que le face à face et
très archétypale voilà et que c'est plus
compliqué que ça et moi ça m'a ça m'a
fait signer parce qu'en fait je pense
qu'il faut les deux mais vous dites
surtout vous dans votre livre c'est très
intéressant que vous avez dû vous vous
dépouiller de tout vos connaissances
pour vous les auteurs qui avait compté
pour vous et et des auteurs qui mettait
en avant la liberté bien sûr est que et
qu'en fait aujourd'hui cette forme de
liberté cette forme de presque deux
libéralismes mon sens de la pensée par
les dynamiques ne fonctionne plus donc
il ya une redéfinition parce que ça que
je dis c'est là on a besoin de cette
écriture et et à une mort à moi même
parce que moi je suis enfin j'ai grandi
en lisant montaigne pas marx j'ai grandi
en étant fasciné par monter ce que j'ai
grandi en préférant voltaire à rousseau
enfin c'est dans tous ses choix de
cantat eagle j'ai toujours un genre a
promis la liberté oui exactement
surchauffe sur le collectif même est
sûre et sur le tout la pensée du tout
moi je me suis toujours méfié de cette
pensée du tout simplement si on est
sincère dans ses démarches
on doit quand même quand on traverse sa
propre société se rende compte de ce que
peut produire notre logiciel
or aujourd'hui quand on quand on
traverse notre pays on se demande quoi
on rencontre quoi on rencontre pas
l'absence de libertés individuelles ce
qu'on rencontre c'est l'absence de sens
collectif
la désarticulation de la société le fait
que selon que vous habitez d'un côté du
périphérique ou de l'autre vous ne
participez plus au même peuple et à la
même et et à la même société
de fait que vous êtes dans une zone
périphérique ou périurbaines et bien ce
qui dans le 10e arrondissement de paris
est vécu comme une libération une
émancipation devient soudain une
servitude est une aliénation et donc
vous devez quand même faire retour et
vous demander qu'est ce qui manque le
plus aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est
voltaire réellement ou est ce que c'est
une forme rousseauiste d' approche de la
démocratie est ce qui manque aujourd'hui
donc d'un côté la revendication d'une
liberté un peu sous toutes les formes et
ça n'empêche pas l'autre mais du collège
essayent de fuir le dogmatisme parce que
le dogmatique y vas y vas nier l'impact
de sa propre pensée sur la réalité
moi j'essaye de d'être fidèle à aristote
à l'étonnement d'aristote qu'il place
aux principes de la philosophie c'est à
dire vous laisser les faits ébranlé vos
propres catégories de pensée vous
laisser les fait pénétrer votre boucher
et oui et vous cherchez des justes au
mieux mais le juste une allure au centre
de mes le juste me oui mais le juste
milieu chez aristote peut être tout à
fait radical aristote il dit aussi
l'homme qui ne s'est pas s'énerver face
à une situation qui nécessite
l'énervement et bien ce n'est pas un
sage c'est un apathique c'est-à-dire un
fou et donc si la situation est radical
si les dangers sont radicaux si les
déséquilibres sont radicaux on peut
devoir formuler pensée radicale on n'est
pas obligé le juste milieu c'est pas le
centre mou le juste milieu c'est
l'adéquation à la situation qu'on pense
appréhender pas douter bien faire la
politique la pole et la philosophie
passage de la politique parce que c'est
aux tornades sont très utiles pour
penser l'engagement alors mais c'est le
constat que vous faites quand même dans
les enfants du vide c'est justement ça
te perdre une idéologie qui paraissait
avant comme étant un obstacle aussi qui
ne seront que tu recules notre société
et le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui
cette absence soit 2 d'idéologie même
dans le pire sens du terme n'a été
remplacé par rien il ya un manque c'est
le vide dont vous parlez des enfants de
vide c'est nous en fait ce sont nous qui
sommes voilà alors vous partez de mai-68
vous dis suis un enfant de mai 68 votre
votre position marcel gauchet par
rapport à ça que vous avez assisté
différemment à ce changement là est ce
que vous pensez qu'il manque d'idées
nous manquons de but à suivre nous
manquons peut-être d'utopie de ceux qui
viendraient revérifier la démocratie
nous manquons tout simplement d'horizons
et de perspective de transformation du
monde où nous sommes pour un nouveau
robespierre non il n'est pas de saison
et puis d'ailleurs robespierre ils
n'arrivent pas toutes armées il n'est
dans un événement qui auquel il adhère
il était tout à fait anodin inoffensif
et banal quand il arrive aux états
généraux en 1789 c'est l'événement qui
va me faire apparaître dans sa dimension
3 2
2 comment un événement qui fait mais je
crois que dans l'histoire c'est
généralement comme ça que ça se passe
c'est les événements donne aux individus
l'occasion d'exprimer une phase de même
qu'il n'aurait pas pu rester
parfaitement l'attend sans les
circonstances donc c'est pas le grand-am
qu'il faut aller chercher un scrutin les
candidats c'est pas comme ça que les
choses se passent le le vide dont nous
parlons est en fait liée à cet évènement
qu'est le triomphe des droits de l'homme
ce qui par un côté est un événement
extraordinairement positive dont il faut
se féliciter parce qu'il n'ya plus le
négatif en eux qui tout simplement ils
ont gagné parce que l'adversaire a
disparu c'est à dire là les droits de
l'homme la contrainte collective qui
régnait encore que j'ai bien connu dans
ma jeunesse qui fait que j'avais
participé à 68 avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé c'est précisément à cause
de cette dimension là mais elle s'est
évanouie pour des raisons qui j'ai
essayé un intérieur mais c'est et tout
se passe comme si nous étions au bout de
l'histoire il n'ya plus d'horizon prend
alors la même on peut en trouver
quelques uns
oui allez-y ajouté je suis d'accord sur
le fait que les droits de l'homme seul
s'ils sont pris seul comme seul horizon
et bien ne permettent plus de créer du
lien collectif et donc de faire de la
politique mais il ya quand même une
autre raison que le trion des droits de
l'homme dans la désarticulation de nos
sociétés c'est quand même le triomphe du
capitalisme le plus débridé
c'est à dire que oui sauf que moi ce que
ce que je pensais
le triomphe des seuls droits de l'homme
ont désarmé le politique pour s'opposer
à quelque chose qui n'a pas besoin des
droits de l'homme en fait pour exister
qui est le triomphe des intérêts
particuliers les plus massifs et les
plus déréguler les plus mondialisées
aujourd'hui et donc c'est quand même
plus classe
justement c'est ce que ce que je veux
dire c'est que en fait il ya une forme
du brise qui va aboutir de démesure qui
va aboutir à la négation finalement
aussi des droits de l'homme qui est
celle des puissants qui ont en gros se
sont émancipés de toute structure
collective dans les années 80 c'est
parce qu'ils ont dit c'est quand même
thatcher reagan
un nouveau rapport à l'économie et aux
halles explosion fantastique des
inégalités sur l'économie qui
fonctionnement la ligue il ya un lien
intime entre la situation que vous
décrivez qu'être est juste et ce
triomphe des droits de l'homme non pas
que les droits de l'homme soit la cause
de la vague néolibérale que vous évoquez
bien entendu mais le l'imaginaire
néolibérale c'est celui d'une planète
d'individus il n'y a plus de collectif
en position de d'encadrer alors qu'on
veut quand même
alors moi je vous dis y'a quand même un
combat qu'on entend qui prend beaucoup
de former compris des tracteurs ça
l'europe aujourd'hui l'europe quand même
est un horizon que les gens essaient
d'investir qui est politiquement
représente une très grande force et que
vous critiquer vivement je crois marcel
gaucher lui je critique la manière dont
on a organisé cette europe qui s'est
précisément mise au service de cet
universalisme capitaliste vendu au
peuple comme l'universalisme de leurs
droits ce dont ils sont en train de
s'apercevoir que c'est pas tout à fait
le cas
même si en effet les l'europe est un
espace de liberté exceptionnel
c'est aussi un espace où le sacrifice a
été fait de du cadre collectif au profit
de l'économie globale et c'est là dessus
que but aujourd'hui l'adhésion à peine
le pion à l'individu et le collectif on
peut la retrouver entre le souverainisme
et
et la défense de l'europe vous êtes
plutôt du côté du souverainisme et je
déteste ce mot d'ailleurs parce que je
l'aïe pour commencer il ne veut rien
dire parce que c'est à dire quelqu'un
non il renvoie des individus qui peuvent
éventuellement le revendiquer mais quand
on regarde ce que ça signifie
concrètement ça n'a aucun contenu
véritable il ya des positions très dures
défendre l'intérêt d'un pays avant celui
l'europe c'est très clair ce que ça
signifie je ne pense pas c'est parce que
disent d'ailleurs les souverainistes en
général pour autant qu est ce que ça va
être précieux non pas du tout là que je
pense que c'est encore une fois la
question qu'on a qu'on sait l'europe
était avait à être un instrument et on
en a fait une fin en soi un instrument
un instrument un instrument d'identité
et de co2 puissance collective qu'on
reconstitue est un échelon supérieur en
fonction de la taille du monde c'était
ça le problème européen et on ne l'a pas
fait partager l'europe asservie à
dissoudre la réalité politique du
continent européen dans un océan globale
sur lequel n'avons plus aucune prise
qu'à l'europe afin de propager le
capitalisme est à proscrire ailleurs si
vous permettez à merano à propos de la
notion de souveraineté elle connaît un
dernier avatar très intéressant quand
emmanuel macron parle de souveraineté
européenne
alors pourquoi la souveraineté serait
mauvaise dans un cas est bonne dans un
an maintenant temps de souveraineté
anti-européenne les pannes jusqu'à 500
réalité on nous sommes tous appartement
on est démocrate
on est tous dit souverainiste oui on est
aux normes souveraineté c'est comme le
pauvre ghezzal des moqueries nissan
nourrir on mais il ya un problème de
nationalisme on pourrait dire alors ce
genre oui oui dans la construction même
parce qu'il n'envisage de souveraineté
qu'à l'échelle nationale donc c'est ça
ce qu'on appelle souverainiste
aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle
souverainiste c'est pas simplement
qu'ils sont pour la souveraineté parce
qu'on nous sommes tous pour la
souveraineté
une vraie nature mais dans le cadre de
réflexion sur l'europe fc qui sait
qu'ils sont convaincus que la seule
souveraineté possible c'est celle qui
s'exerce à l'échelle de la nation
or ce que vous partagez ce constat non
moi je pense qu'il ya besoin d'une
souveraineté européenne
que le problème qu'on a c'est
qu'effectivement et là dessus je suis
d'accord l'europe n'est pas une fin en
fait et c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre
et c'est ça que les gens qui comme moi
sont très partisans de la construction
européenne à telle qu'elle est menée
actuellement mais dans l'idée d'un
dépassement des seules nations et bien
fond on fait souvent cette erreur nous
c'est que l'autre ne peut pas être une
fin l'europe doit être jeu légitime et
fondée en légitimité dans ce qu'elle
peut produire
et qu'est-ce que dans qu'est ce qu'elle
peut produire qu'est ce qu'elle peut
produire pendant 70 ans
en gros le sens de l'europe c'était il
ya eu le fascisme il ya eu la guerre et
donc l'europe doit produire la paix
soixante dix ans après ça suppose de
fonder cela juste sur la mémoire en
fonde pas un projet collectif comme
l'europe sur la simple mémoire des
tragédies passées donc il faut ancrer
l'europe dans des tragédies actuelle à
venir
ça c'est faisable c'est faisable mais à
condition qu'on change la perception
qu'on a de l'europe la manière de la
faire c'est à dire que aujourd'hui par
exemple pour moi l'horizon qui permet de
relégitimer l'europe c'est l'horizon de
la catastrophe écologique
si on veut affronter le réchauffement
climatique
on a besoin de l'échelle européenne donc
l'europe là c'est parce qu'ils ont une
mémoire c'est une garantie pour que nous
puissions agir sur quelque chose qui
nous menacent c'est à dire le changement
climatique est simplement ont ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que si on veut que
l'europe fasse cela alors elle doit
changer
parce qu'en réalité l'europe aujourd'hui
telle qu'elle est faite elle empêche
mais cela aux gens disent il faut que
l'europe restait lequel elle y compris
les français connaissent pas vraiment
prenez par exemple la règle la règle des
3% et qui est fondée et qui devient la
règle déficit de 3% qui devient une
sorte de dogme européen une fondation de
la construction européenne mais si on a
besoin de réellement mener cette
transformation écologique il faudra
qu'on engage des dépenses que la
politique puisse à nouveau décidé de son
budget et donc l'europe deviendra un
problème alors que ça doit être la
solution
et pourquoi on prend on en arriver à
cela c'est parce qu'en fait on a
complètement des politiques
c'est la question européenne moi j'ai
une grande polémique avec jean luc
mélenchon à ce propos c'est que lui dit
c'est le résultat l'europe actuelle dans
le hareng de bismarck de l'impérialisme
allemand
c'est dix marques c'est ça a donné le
troisième reich du quatrième bref c'est
cette volonté hégémonique de la moi je
pense que l'europe actuelle dans ses
défauts c'est à dire l'antipolitisme et
l'ordo libéralisme c'est le produit
exactement de l' inverse c'est le
produit de 1945 la fondation de la rfa
et d'une immense méfiance à juste titre
d élite allemande nouvelle vis-à-vis de
toute forme de souveraineté démocratique
puisque le peuple avait choisi claire le
peuple avait entraîné le monde dans le
chaos le peuple avait tué six millions
de juifs en nommant huit en élisant
hitler et qu'il fallait donc mettre à
distance la politique enserrée la
politique d'un ensemble de normes donner
le pouvoir aux experts et non plus aux
citoyens donner le pouvoir à ceux qui
savent et non plus à ceux qui votent et
c'est ça qui a fait qu'on a sanctifiée
l'indépendance de la banque sans que tu
fier les règles de droit et qu'on a
laissé le moins de politique possible
dans cette construction le problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui salvini norman en
gris le brésil est bien aussi douloureux
ce soit à admettre c'est une revanche de
la politique alors mais quand même vous
avez dit voilà les enfants du jus de
l'absence d'idéologie il n'ya pas
d'horizon commun qui nous permettraient
de construire quelque chose de collectif
qui permet de dépasser l'individualisme
dans ce cri l'a22 plus délétère vous
avez parlé à l'instant de l'écologie
rappelle lé oxman et même les mêmes
juste l'écologie ce n'est pas une
idéologie c'est une réalité c'est un
horizon commun
moi je précisément alors je repense à ce
jour n'a rien en commun mais je pense
qu'on ne les embrasse pas assez je pense
que en fait on est en quête on est on
habite un vide on est en quête de sens
sont en quête d'horizons et en réalité
il est là l'horizon de transformation
collective de nos sociétés gèrent quand
il ya quinze mille scientifiques du
monde entier qui signent tribune qui a
notamment fait la une du monde
on est tous en alerte est sur l'état de
la planète utilisent qu'il nous reste
peu de temps maintenant mais qui dit
demain il sera trop tard et cie ont même
pas les transformations radicales dès
aujourd'hui de nos modes de production
de consommation et bien nous allons dans
le mur dans le nord ça veut dire
dans la spirale de la catastrophe
climatique eh bien il faut les écouter
et il nous donne là l'horizon tragique
qui nous permettra d'ailleurs de
réhabiliter le politique face aux
intérêts pas vous dire ils inversent
marcel gauchet que l'écologie ne va pas
réhabiliter la politique non entendons
nous bien
la crise écologique donné mais le projet
écologique c'est autre chose c'est à
dire le l'urgence écologique c'est
d'urgence d'une survie de l'humanité par
rapport à une planète en passe de
devenir inhabitables dans un horizon
rapproché mais qu'elle aura lequel sera
la forme de cette société c'est bien là
où il ya une grande animant ce dilemme
autour de l'écologie on peut avoir un
fascisme et écologique c'est-à-dire des
régimes autoritaires qui impose de
manière violente des restrictions parce
que bel et bien il s'agit pour nous de
renoncer de nous priver de diminuer le
règne de nos désirs de toutes sortes
à commencer par le maroc en termes de
mobilité en termes de dépenses de toutes
sortes
ça peut être fait sur un mode
autoritaire c'est le grand risque
d'ailleurs à mon avis c'est notre
problème
à partir du moment même spontanément
c'est un des éléments qui font revenir
la dimension autoritaire dans la
politique dans la conscience condamner
des gens
seule la contrainte peut permettre
d'organiser une survie écologique
ça peut être au contraire c'est sur la
mode démocratique ça va être ça le
dilemme du siècle mais bien sûr mais
pour l'instant la tentation autoritaire
elle est portée par des individus
politique comme trump ou comme bolt
narrow comme sale unis qui n'ont ni ni
qui ni le problème écologique et qui
sont et qui mène même des politiques
écocide et donc ça veut dire que bien
sûr qu'on peut se soucier cjce heure
d'un jeu stérile autour de ribérou on
peut toujours se soucier
oui mais c'est là où est la menace
aujourd'hui on peut toujours se soucier
de ce que l'écologie pourrait finir par
avoir comme robespierrisme pour vous
reprendre votre votre
ouvrage mais aujourd'hui la menace avait
pas là aujourd'hui la menace c'est la
conjonction entre des politiques qui nie
le led le cataclysme écologique est une
forme d'autoritarisme débridée donc ça
veut dire que ce que je voulais dire
simplement c'est que le souci écologique
ne suffit pas à définir une politique
écologique et retrouve un la politique
c'est précisément être en mesure de
comprendre comment on peut articuler une
la réduction de nos modes de vie
l'horizon obligatoire et un style de
fonctionnement des mots clés ma
participation réelle mais parce que
c'est ce que je pense ce soir et
l'écologie ne peut pas rendre
redynamiser la politique en tant que tel
simplement un souci commun ce qui
pourrait donner remplir cet horizon
juste réussi s'est-elle l'urgence
écologique permet de réhabiliter le
débat politique dans ce qu'il a de
meilleur
lorsqu'il dit on à mantoue mai mais je
faisais un mix man mais qui sont très
difficiles à concevoir parce que parce
que la politique
en fait en soi en fait dans le fait
politique même il ya le risque de toute
façon de la dérive robespierristes c'est
à dire que la l'écologie une charte unl
à l'écologie bah oui à partir de lundi
qu'on dépasse l'individu pour aller vers
un horizon collectif dans lequel
l'individu s'inscrit il ya forcément le
risque de la dérive autoritaire et de la
contrainte et donc ce que l'écologie
permet à mon avis si on apprend c'est à
dire si c'est pas juste des tweets ou d
où d où d exhortation à la vidéo ouais à
changer nos comportements individuels
mais où on prend réellement en compte le
péril qui nous fasse et donc la
nécessité du politique
pour y faire face et bien l'écologie
elle réhabilite la notion même d espaces
publics c'est-à-dire à nouveau on
comprend qu'on ne vit pas dans
l'illimité et ont rejoint ce que hegel
dit sur la guerre c'est à dire que
comment on fait quand on est à une
société qui vit dans l'illusion de la
paix perpétuelle pour maintenir un état
on peut peindre
parce que chaque parti va penser qu'elle
est autonome et donc on a besoin quand
on est un état de déclencher des guerres
laon pour rappeler aux parties qu'elles
appartiennent à un tout là on peut le
faire sans déclencher de guerre contre
nos voisins
en prenant en compte le fait qu'on est
déjà en fait en guerre contre notre
environnement et qu'il s'agit est bien
de sortir de cette guerre là est fou un
ennemi nos positions pour la démocratie
alors totale et tarissement face à la
crise écologique permet de réinjecter
nom d'aimé dans la démocratie mais nous
dévions désignons le bon ennemi
d'écologie fin l'écologie justement le
réchauffement climatique est parfait
pour fédérer peut-être l'allèle m'aimez
vous devez ouvrir la discussion mais
fédérer si on peut voir trancher c'est à
dire que ça et le thé en direction est
bien assis sur votre tabouret
heureusement jusqu'au bout cette
émission je demande à chacun de mes
invités dans cette émission de venir
avec trois livres
trois livres qui ont compté pour eux des
livres de chevet des livres qui sont en
train de lire en ce moment marcel
gauchet quels sont les livres que vous
avez apporté
écoutez je nie j'ignorais complètement
en l'apportant qu'il serait en plein
dans notre sujet parce que c'est un
livre qui a vient du passé mais c'est
les pensées de pascal qui sédition la
vieille édition brin cheville qui est le
maître de la pensée subtile pour
laquelle nous plaît donc je pense qu'il
est le premier à l'avoir introduit avec
ce génie dans la formulation qui fait
que je regrette et couvre à chaque fois
avec bonheur cette manière absolument
stupéfiante de donner à penser la
contradiction humaines les paradoxes de
la condition humaine et je suis aussi un
grand enfant de quatre ans m
je ne cherche pas l'illumination mais
j'y trouve un exemple très exactement de
cette discipline de penser une chose et
l'autre à la fois que nous avons essayer
d'illustrer dans la mesure de nos moyens
merci quelle heure vous en avez 4 je
vois un jeune avait 4 ditto rapidement
se sont toujours d'ailleurs des auteurs
qui est un livre de chevet c'est un
livre qui inépuisable parce qu'il
apporte sans arrêt sans cesse même si on
ne connaît presque par coeur une
stimulation a fini dans le genre les
cahiers de paul valéry me semble que
c'est un choix et on peut certainement
discuter mais en deux
une zone appelée yard on a déjà beaucoup
et c'est un auteur que je ne me lasse
pas d'admirer tellement il est une
source infinie pour la réflexion il est
l'exemple même de la discipline
intellectuelle pour moi c'est à dire il
n'est rien qui ne puisse être remis en
question de ce qu'on croit de ce qu'on
pense il ya un retour permanent pour se
remettre en question et remettre en
question ce qu'on entend et bien c'est
noté qu'elles sont les deux autres
chevaux hannah arendt hannah arendt
condition de l'homme moderne c'est la
vieille édition il y en a en poche il
existe dans une meilleure reddition en
quarto gallimard condition de l'homme
moderne c'est l'exemple même format du
livre source onu je suis très souvent
des accords avec elle mais je suis
fasciné par la manière admirable dont
elle mais le problème condition de
l'homme moderne en forme et dans un
langage qui inspire la réflexion à
toutes les lignes pour ainsi dire je
leur lis très régulièrement et chaque
fois avec à nouveau un nouveau regard
sur ce qu'elle a voulu dire et je suis
très souvent encore une fois en
désaccord avec elle mais elle pensait
contre + mêmes pensées contre vous même
c'est qu'est-ce que vous avez un et
quatre l'est par un ordre quatrième un
livre un peu d'un autre ordre que je
n'ai couvert n'y a pas très longtemps
parce qu'il est paru en français il ya
simplement quelques années sont les
essais de virginia wolf que c'est la
forme et la réflexion le talent
d'écriture éblouissant pour moi je ne
connais rien d'aussi magistralement
écrit pensée explosé elle prend un sujet
ça peut être un auteur est une question
il ya beaucoup mais beaucoup ont des
droits des femmes et à chaque fois c'est
un renouvellement complet par la manière
souveraine dont elle le dit bon bah
c'est bien noté merci marcel gauchet
raffermi oxman bien sympathique
c'est la fin des bibliothèques par
contre en mai non mariés ils sont ma
bibliothèque
j'avais pas compris que je vais ramener
je suis désolé et donc tout d'abord
puisque c'était lié à notre discussion
et c'est le fil rouge de ma réflexion
depuis quelques années le discours sur
la première décade de tite-live de
machiavel qui revient tout au long de
votre ouvrage et qui est réellement mon
livre de chevet c'est à dire qu'on
connaît le machiavel du prince mais on
oublie souvent que c'est le grand
penseur de la république et que il le
produit ce discours là un moment qui
ressemble étrangement au nôtre c'est à
dire que il doit lui le penseur
républicain fuir florence parce qu'il a
été défait par les puissances de
l'argent par les puissances des médicis
et donc il se pose la question de
pourquoi en fait at on perdu
et qu'est ce que rome peut nous
apprendre sur la manière de vivre en
république
c'est le premier le second nous reste
une minute désolé le second c'est un
livre de poésie c'est les poésies de
mallarmé puisque je pense que c'est le
plus immense poète qui soit et que je
j'ai toujours été animé par cette
question qui est comment peut-on écrire
après mallarmé et c'est une question à
laquelle j'ai toujours pas de réponse
mais rien gc je suis devenu
réactionnaire le jeu ou mallarmé mort en
fait et le troisième est bien le
troisième c'est
la promesse de l'aube parce que c'est un
héros magal romain gary parce que c'est
à mon avis le plus beau texte qui soit à
la fois sur l'amour et sur ce que
signifie notre pays la france bien c'est
noté merci pour ces lectures avant de
nous quitter je vous propose de regarder
comme chaque mois un sujet un
partenariat avec le centre national du
livre cette fois ci nous sommes allés à
brive festival de brive ou plusieurs
auteurs évoquent l'importance de ce
festival dans leur carrière
il s'agit cette fois-ci de christian
signol amélie nothomb mais jean louis
debré c'est un sujet d'eloïse grégoire
la mairie de brive la sncf et toute
l'équipe des trains spéciaux vous
souhaite la bienvenue à bord de notre
train à destination de brive la
gaillarde
arrivée prévue 13h50 depuis 33 ans agent
éditeurs écrivains le tout paris des
lettres se retrouve dans ce train du
livre unique en france
la foire de brive ses soixante dix mille
visiteurs qui parcourent chaque année
c'est aller gratuitement à la rencontre
des auteurs pendant trois jours la
mémoire de cette foire c'est lui
christian signol depuis 33 ans il vient
à brive jeu tant que brive même les
auteurs de
des éditeurs les lectures tout le monde
tous d'une manière générale que c'est
beaucoup plus commun dire chaleureux que
le contact s'établit beaucoup plus
facilement encore une fois entre les
éclairer
et les lecteurs c'est peut-être ce qui
en fait sa singularité du moins je le
crois
fidèle parmi les fidèles la dame en noir
amélie nothomb ben est une habituée des
lieux
la romancière a tissé un lien affectif
avec la foire de brive la toute première
fête du livre à laquelle j'ai participé
c'était brive il y à peine 6 ans j'étais
une gamine genève bruxelles la première
fois que j'ai
vraiment ont rencontré mes lecteurs
c'était abri et j'ai eu un deal
accueilli ici les 26 ans alors que je
n'étais personne que j'ai eu un coup de
foudre exceptionnelle pour brive ici les
lecteurs interpelle facilement les
écrivains c'est d'ailleurs l'une des
particularités de la foire ça allait
coller partout c'est la magie aux
papillons
jean louis debré vient depuis 12 ans à
brive
pour lui c'est un moment festif et de
partage une ambiance assez exceptionnel
avec
si on aime
des bons plats si on aime la gastronomie
alors vous avez le libre et la
gastronomie
quel bonheur il y a quelques années le
lauréat du goncourt s'annonçait ici à
brive et non restaurant drouant
une page s'est donc tournée même s'il
n'ya plus la récompense les auteurs
prestigieux sont toujours bien présents
j'imagine que vous connaissez le
festival l'imprévu
raphaël glucksmann et marcel gauchet
entendu pas vous serez invités très
bientôt j'imagine mal grâce à ce
reportage donc en partenariat avec le
cnl merci à tous les deux d'être revenue
aujourd'hui par les nouveaux ouvrages
marcel gauchet robespierre l'homme qui
nous divise le plus raphaël glucksmann
les enfants du vide de l'impasse
individualiste au réveil citoyen votre
livre est à aux éditions gallimard
marcel gauchet le vôtre avec luc semaine
aux éditions alary on se quitte comme
chaque semaine avec une chanson un jeu
de mots un peu facile sur un beau
dernier ouvrage marcel gauchet fin
dernier qui remonte à et un petit bout
de temps maintenant
le désenchantement du monde mais est
revenu dessus en 2004 un monde
désenchanté
il s'agit donc de les enchanter cette
fois-ci par mylène farmer
merci et à très bientôt
[Musique]
key to
béchir
[Musique]
m
c'était livrez vous avec le concours du
centre national du livre
[Musique]